if you would please rise and raise your
right hand I will begin by swearing you
in the wild-card witness no one knew the
fee you ambassador Gordon Sunland would
help or hurt president Trump his
testimony turned out to be the most
damning yet mr. Giuliani's requests were
a quid pro quo for arranging a White
House visit for president Solinsky mr.
Giuliani demanded that Ukraine make a
public statement announcing the
investigations of the 2016 election DNC
server and burry smih we worked with mr.
Giuliani because the president directed
us to do so Purisima refers to Joe Biden
Sunland also tied the push for an
investigation of Trump's political rival
to the Secretary of State vice president
and acting chief of staff everyone was
in the loop it was no secret Republicans
who have insisted there was no quid pro
quo couldn't disguise their dismay
Gordon Sunland does not meet the
criticisms they have levelled at other
witnesses he donated to Trump's
inauguration fund so he is not a
so-called never Trump er he offered this
new insight on the president's desire
for Ukraine to dig dirt on his political
rival Joe Biden he had to announce the
investigations he didn't actually have
to do them as I understood it okay
president Solinsky had to announce the
two investigations the president wanted
make a public announcement correct
correct but he's not the Democrats
perfect witness while he directly ties a
White House meeting to the quid pro quo
he's unable to do the same with military
aid president Trump confirmed that
President zalenski needed to publicly
announce the investigations or otherwise
the obvious implication of the stalemate
would be that the aide would not be
released is that correct
again the implication I did not hear
directly from President Trump that the
aide would be held up until the
statement was made I did not hear those
words he also called
rated Trump's defense which he unusually
gave from emphatically handwritten notes
I want nothing I want nothing I want no
quid pro quo tell szalinski to do the
right thing then he says this is the
final word from the President of the
United States
I want nothing thank you folks have a
good time anointed ambassador soglin's
testimony is a big test of Republican
oil tea to Donald Trump he's offered the
strongest corroboration so far of what
the Democrats alleged that the u.s.
president pressured a foreign power to
interfere in a u.s. election for his own
political gain
most people agree that's wrong
the bigger question is whether it's
impeachable Amanda Walker Sky News
Washington